so mr olympia do you have any
predictions you kind of have an idea
yeah you know right now uh you have the
reigning champion uh big grammy yeah um
more than likely he is the favorite he
is the guy that's gonna repeat
who's standing in his way is uh hadi
chopin from iran yeah he's trained by my
trainer honey rambot and i've been able
to see some pics
he's looking really dangerous right now
what's the chances of hadi beating rami
i think it's
all about who peaks not just on friday
but who slams the door on saturday
i definitely feel that the way that
judging criteria is is not swayed to
just rammy because rammy has only peaked
truly maybe a couple times in his career
and i know his trainer chad nichols who
trained ronnie coleman who worked with
him for all those olympia wins
understands
how imperative it is to not just do
friday but also saturday the timing of
it the timing is everything i mean
that's something that i you know made
sure of
but with hottie he does not
miss
so i think with ramy being the size that
he is
he can miss maybe one of those days so
and then you have brandon curry i mean
you know he's a former mr olympia he's a
one-time so that's really your top three
and i'm really excited to see those
three guys get up there and then you
have the guys like william bonak you
have nick walker nick walker who just
won the arnold classic yeah a lot of
hype going in yeah it's it's gonna be
good nick win couldn't does nick stand a
chance to be first place no okay no top
three
maybe if some guys miss how big of a
deal is it to win the arnold classic
going into mr oh like is it a really
really big deal or not i think this year
it helps him tremendously because of the
fact that the arnold was two weeks prior
to the olympia normally the arnold
classic is in march
so you have like that six months yeah is
it healthy phil to have it to be that
close to each other like mr olympia and
arnold i mean health wise that's gotta
be it's definitely difficult to to peak
for a two-day show doing a one-day show
i mean
that's easy yeah but when you're doing a
one-day show and then two weeks after
that you've got to do a two-day show
yeah
you know the peaking
what do you mean what do you mean by
peaking phil and like how long is that
window you're talking so you have to
consider like let's just say
you have a usain bolt he's getting ready
for the olympics but he's doing like an
event like an invitational like let's
say a month prior
let's just say he wants a world record
time in the world you know before the
olympics is that smart
probably not because you really want to
win
the olympic final with the world record
time so it's all about the timing so you
kind of have to pace yourself but the
problem is the body is not static is
very very dynamic so whatever worked for
nick
or anyone for these previous shows
you have to now realize that diet that
training
you might want to just rip that up and
just look at what's going on with your
body right now
and that's something that a lot of
people
miss
so a lot of people that even watch this
they've dieted but because of the fact
that their body does change
and they didn't change with it yeah they
they miss so that's why all these fad
diets keep going so but bodybuilders
have that problem too
so so you got for you like let's just
say by the way does vegas have odds on
these things or no those vegans they
should they don't but they don't okay
why not because it's well
yeah it's kind of sticky with the
that's very i i wouldn't if i was going
to be bought
oh 100
like pat said there's a reason why
there's no vegas odds in this i mean
people could be compromised in some way
shape or form i mean we don't need to go
down there that could be a whole nother
you think that's a good thing that
there's not a vegas odds yeah i think so
one million percent yeah the integrity
of it
at least in boxing you know
boxing is one of the dirtiest when it
comes down to manipulating and buying
people out i've had people on that have
told me you have no idea what kind of
people have bought and how much how easy
it is to buy that right in bodybuilding
it's very uh uh what do you call it it's
you know technical yet you can kind of
say well objective yeah subjective
that's the word i'm looking forward to
be objective yet subjective so like if
you look at all the mr olympia champions
they're all different in their own way
so right now you have ramy like that's a
guy that is pull up rammy i would like
to see there's no one that looks like
rammy right i love a big ramekin so
there's no one that looks like him he's
like he's like the modern day ronnie
right there it's not a runner the guy's
gonna be over 300 pounds ripped oh damn
no one's gonna look like this yeah kai
pull up with some images of these guys
who are we looking okay no no do the one
with ronnie and uh romney right next to
each other even though it's not real
click on that no no okay this is my
instagram post if you can pull up
look at that right there to do them
insane what rami looks like
so that's randy on the right phil was as
big as these guys when he was winning
well it was i was definitely not the
same weight as rammy you know even he's
on the right yes and ronnie's on the
left yeah so like when my last olympia
win in 2017 i actually did
um beat rammy
and uh you beat the guy in the right
yeah damn phil why beat these guys were
over 10 plus years
back to back to back i know who phil is
but uh but ramy is definitely one of
those guys that even when i was winning
yeah i would see him and say
if this guy gets in real good shape yeah
he's going to be a problem for everybody
so first place romney second place
rami hottie uh probably brandon nick
i don't have you know what's funny i i
actually
my oddball is william bonac
because he didn't do the arnold
and i think it gave him maybe more time
to peak for the olympia could it be top
three i think so i mean like it's just
well here's my money my money
would be
a one a one b with hottie and rammy
because they're so different yet dude if
hottie wins oh man it's gonna crazy if
he wins this is rammy right here go on
howdy chopin yeah who's hot howdy chopin
wins the olympia i may have to drive up
to orlando congratulations guy gets the
spelling right it's zero h-h-a-d-i yeah
there you go there you go click on that
everybody's looking for that there you
go they want that this is what people
want they want is he indian hottie the
guy the right is persian so they want
they want egypt egypt versus iran
basically is that oh he's egyptian he's
around but rami is
look at the legs but look at even but
here's the thing yeah
look at look at rammy but then look at
hottie
deeper cuts
you know much deeper separation so these
are things that like this is this is the
judging this has to be seen live because
to me that there's it's indecipherable
so so it's so here's what i would
suggest
what if phil on saturday night okay
what if you go live and you watch mr
olympia live and you give feedback on it
and anybody that wants to tune in they
can tune in and see you giving feedback
on the contest [ __ ] it i say we do it
you're not gonna go no i'm not going
you're not going i'm not going so okay
why not why not
why why wouldn't the fans want to see me
do commentary on on the guys you'd
rather you'd rather at the end of the
day i mean i'm gonna give these guys
justice okay you know i definitely feel
that um
they would want to know my opinion
yeah but more importantly
i've competed against these guys for
over 10 years
i understand their strengths their
weaknesses
but
i have no axe to grind either
which is great
and i'm gonna be unbiased well the best
part is and unfortunately in our sport
it's one of those things where you
happen to
look at something
and then you just [ __ ] on it
because you're looking at their
weaknesses yeah and i think you don't
sell the sport without yeah you're going
to talk about the weaknesses but you're
going to highlight their strengths
because at the end of the day this is
what these guys train for
it's the person who has the most
strength and the least amount of
weaknesses wins i have a question for
you phil and this may be the
entire audience can kind of get some
perspective here
everyone out there gets judged on their
performance their work performance how
they're looking you know you show up to
the office oh you're rough night but uh
it's constantly you're on social media
people are hating people are commenting
whatever you are putting yourself out
there for the world to see literally
every inch of your body minus right 100
percent
my question is regarding self-confidence
and body image do you ever like get on
stage and be like i don't know i don't
feel so good today or
the judgment the cause of judgment that
like every like instagram models are
you know they they clean up every little
image every little curve are you
thinking about it are you coming
thinking
that you know before i get on there i
gotta understand what the mentality of
it all at the end of the day break that
down you know what to get on for his
birthday already 100 percent one of
those absolutely i got him
yeah the beginning what color is
no i'm thinking
magenta okay i could do it i could pull
that off would you take that picture and
post it on instagram
how much money i could be bought i could
give me i could be i could be buying
but at the end of the day yes
bodybuilders have
definitely i mean i'm raising my hand
right now
the insecurity absolutely the anxiety
that these guys and these girls are
going through this week they've trained
an entire year
to get ready to go up on stage and be
adjudicated by
judges who
may or may not like their physique and
then they're going to be adjudicated by
millions of people on social media
to reduce the noise is what is key for
each male and female that is competing
this week reducing the noise staying
within yourself
because there's this thing that my
trainer and i call the the f up fairy
and the f up ferry is going to creep
into your mind it's kind of like what
fighters go through
you know they kind of go dark they get
get weird and sometimes that's how they
get knocked the hell out in the first
round because they really get in their
head about what's going on
it's important
that each and these each of these people
know who the hell they are
and realize that it's you versus you
you cannot control it's not like boxing
where you can go knock the person out
you can't play offense defense you have
to make sure that you peak the best way
you can and that's it and you just have
to
let it let the chips fall but the
insecurity absolutely the anxiety
absolutely i mean i've had it it'll keep
you up at night it'll piss you off i
mean you'll go through various emotions
but that's why the most emotionally
intelligent
know how to run this race and you've won
this seven times let it go i think there
are certain things in life you shouldn't
aspire to do mysteries let me live my
life i say you skipping let me live a
life i say you skip go be go be the wide
receiver for like a local senior uh you
know senior nfl team whatever and you
know do that why shortly we will come
root for you i'll be your biggest fan so
if you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you